ARTHUR BROOKS: What makes you happy?
Would more money, a new relationship,
job, or maybe even a pet
make you happier?
Maybe to be happier, you should
give up all of these things
and go meditate on
the top of a mountain.
Or perhaps happiness
is out of your control,
and you're just programmed to
enjoy it a lot or a little.
If you want to have a truly happy
life, what do you need to focus on?
What should your goals be?
These questions have
puzzled humanity forever,
and many people think
they can't be answered.
It turns out that there's a huge
body of science on human happiness.
Who has it, what causes it,
and the biggest mistakes
we all make when we're
trying to acquire it.
This is a course that brings
all this information to you.
But it does more than just
give you facts and data.
It also teaches you how to use it
in your life, so you can get happier
no matter where you start out.
I'll show you how philosophy, social
science, history, and brain science
all come together to give
us the secret to living
fuller, more meaningful lives.
And I'll teach you
the exercises you need
to make these secrets a
permanent part of your life
and share them with the people you love.
Everybody wants to be happier.
You can make yourself happier,
and this course will show you how.